talk to the viewers right now about
chapters three in your book the five
time assassins and why that's important
so when I wrote the book which I
appreciate you asking that question I
um wrote down 25 of the people that I
loved the most that were entrepreneurs
that I knew struggled with this concept
the most right and as I wrote the book I
would ask myself okay and look my
brother was on there and my wife's on
there and my best friends are on there
and like and then a bunch of other
people right year and dear
and I go as it pertains to these
Frameworks these Concepts and the book
is as you've seen it's not just a time
management book it's actually a bit of
leadership book it's a strategy book
it's a vision book it's it's got the
pieces to really do what I want people
hopefully sell them on it and get them
to implement and execute and as I was
going through these 25 people's names to
figure out like what belief system that
I need to write about in their story and
tool that I need to give them I realized
that some of them didn't fit in the core
Frameworks I was teaching so I created
these five time assassins to kind of
like
bring all the other ones in there right
so the five because I even tweeted this
out this morning I said the number one
thing the cheapest thing you could do to
buy back your time is just turn off all
your notifications on your phone like
all of them like I don't have
notifications on my phone it's such a
weird eye like yesterday I was getting
uh a photo new headshot it's been a
while
um and the the photographer says to me
goes how do you like the new Ultra right
I'm a Garmin guy I do triathlons and
Ironmans and stuff and I moved to the
ultra because he's got a battery life
and he asked me about it and he says
yeah I used to have it but all the
notifications were distracting me when I
was doing my work and when he said that
I was just like turn them off dude like
that was such a fat he he switched
watches because of notifications and
like it's been a decade now I just don't
because I build software I know how
great the PHD doctorates are in the
engineers that build this stuff they
literally are designed oh dude the color
shade of the red notification Jewel on
an icon on your phone it is split tested
to the nth degree like there's books out
there and studies and PhD research Etc
yeah hook but near El and many others I
lived in that world right
um so
the the time assassins and the five of
them are the staller the speed demon the
supervisor the saver and the
self-medicator right they were designed
to tell people like hey even if you
didn't hire another person let's just
address where you're you're losing time
right the staller is somebody that
hesitates by just not making decisions
one of the most productive things you
could do in your life is to be decisive
like it sounds crazy but people waste
More Time by not making a decision than
a decision right so that was a big area
I had this bucket of friends I was like
you guys are stallers and then the speed
demon right rich I don't know about you
but this is definitely it resonates with
me you can be multiple of these I used
to be the guy that would make rapid
decisions like hiring people and
Partnerships and all the stuff only to
find myself dealing with the downside of
those fast speed demon decisions because
I was like I'm making decisions in
business I'm moving forward but I didn't
even have any level of like criteria or
you know the people that post on
Facebook are like I need to hire a new
designer or like they they have a friend
that's like oh my friend's a design I
was like oh I'll hire them it's like are
they the best person really the
supervisor somebody that that can't let
go the micromanager I think we've all
been there at different stages of growth
right but that if you don't do that that
you will always be required the saver is
the Penny Pincher right and this one
this one bugs me a lot Rich because you
probably this is this is your crowd dude
I think it is anyways and you tell me
but these are people that don't
understand that if they want to move
faster they have to make investments
right you you you you don't get Returns
on life on your business on an outcome
you're trying to achieve if you don't
make an investment of time or money
right so like I tell this story about
one of my friends he's running a 2
million a year masterminds 20K to be in
it he calls me up because you know
here's what we're doing and he's like
how did you do that and I was like
well I first off because he was like
frustrated that every event he would do
it just felt like he was like always
doing this like show like how good was
the last event I was like well it's
because you don't have a framework for
what you're teaching it's just kind of
uh come and pay me to feel good about
yourself but there's no like framework
or process or ladder right so I
introduced him this guy Simon Bowen who
is the expert at doing this this is like
Simon is the Mozart of models okay he's
got a company called models that sells
and his response to me was
um well how much is he and I go I don't
know how much he's going to charge you
because I got a bro deal because I
actually helped him on something but you
know it's it's tens of thousands like
it's not nothing but it's not crazy he's
like oh does he have a book
I'm like no he doesn't have a book he's
like all right well let let me go let me
go search online first and see what I
can put together myself and in that
again I didn't say anything like I'm a
I'm a weird cat because here rich I will
tell you how I feel but in person I
don't because it's I like to be the
lighthouse right that's the way I
resolve things so I didn't say anything
to him but in my head I'm thinking
how do you have a two million a year
Mastermind that you're about to shut
down because you hate it that you charge
people 20 grand that a guy that you that
you reached out to me and you know we're
like multiple a figures and I hired the
guy to solve the problem and you're
sitting there going
yeah come on like
holy moly I just I can't deal with that
stuff sometimes and then then the
self-medicator is the person that you
know turns to anything like food alcohol
drugs to to celebrate and to deal with
with stress and to check out and usually
with that comes a lot of downsides in
their life that they have I call it
emotional shrapnel and it sucks a lot of
time energy headspace Etc and I seen
that amongst these 25 friends where like
there was about six or seven I would say
hey you're heavy self-medicator you
can't win without saying we gotta go
celebrate at a meal or I gotta go have a
bunch of drinks and I mean dude that's
that that will and then you got to deal
with the upset wife and then you know
your kid's upset and I mean geez the
most expensive thing is is going through
a divorce I mean you want to talk about
sucking your time and energy up I mean
that'll be a big one so so to me it's
like I had to write this chapter to
address the mindset side of things
before I teach the Tactical because if I
didn't address that I wouldn't have got
people bought in to then say okay
enough's enough I want to solve these
things I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out